[Musica]
[Applauso]
ho amato la natura
fin da piccolo i miei ricordi vanno a
quando guardavo il mondo dall'alto dallo
zaino di mio papà
durante le escursioni estive in montagna
e poi dal basso del mio metro e qualcosa
non appena imparato a camminare e
riconoscere cosa fosse un sentiero mio
padre fotografo naturalista mi ha
insegnato a osservare ea farmi domande
la farfalla che si posava sulla mia mano
gli stambecchi maschi in lotta nella
nebbia autunnale ai minerali che
brillavano al sole
piano piano sono diventati dei compagni
che ritrovavo tutte le estati sulla riva
di questi laghetti alpini ho dato il mio
primo bacio e molti dei viaggi
immaginari che facevo da adolescente
avevano luogo in montagne erano
ambientati li salire verso l'alto a
scoprire nuovi sentieri era ogni volta
un avventura ma anche qualcosa che mi
faceva sentire a casa
estate dopo estate cercare stelle
cadenti nel cielo notturno e una sana
passione per guerre stellari
mi ha fatto venire voglia di conoscere
meglio l'universo
allora ho comprato un libro che spiega
va alle stelle le costellazioni e
leggevo di nebulose di polvere che
creavano pianeti di particelle in
viaggio fin dall'origine dell'universo
di fusione nucleare
al centro del sole tutto aumentava il
mio senso di meraviglia spazi e tempi
immensi erano a portata di un semplice
binocolo anzi a volte li potevo
percepire anche a occhio nudo come
quando trovavo la galassia di andromeda
nel cielo e mi accorgevo di stare
guardando indietro nel tempo di 2
milioni di anni tanto ci aveva messo la
luce ad arrivare ai miei occhi o quando
vedevo il centro della nostra galassia
la via lattea e mi accorgevo che in
fondo io e lei eravamo fatti
praticamente degli stessi elementi
la scuola non era molto bravo in fisica
sapevo fare bene i conti ma di mostrare
i teoremi non era il mio pane però il
mio professore di scienza era un
laureato in scienze forestali disciplina
che non sapevo neanche esistesse mi
spiego che questa materia insegnava non
solo a conoscere la natura ma anche a
lavorare insieme a lei per il bene della
società sembrava un lavoro a contatto
con l'ambiente in più mi affascinava la
prospettiva di mettere un po le mani in
pasta anziché lamentarmi a uno studio da
spettatore così era deciso l'estate
della maturità mi iscrissi a scienze
forestali negli anni dell'università
continuavo ad andare in montagna ma
l'attenzione si spostava ora sul bosco
che fino ad allora consideravo uno
sfondo oppure un noioso intermezzo da
superare il più in fretta possibile per
arrivare un po più in alto
ora invece imparavo a riconoscere gli
alberi a chiamarli per nome a sapere che
ciascuno ha i suoi gusti in fatto di
luce di acqua il suolo dove crescere
soprattutto imparavo che tutte le cose
in natura sono collegate anche su
distanze e tempi che sembrano
impossibili da colmare è un po come i
nostri atomi sono stati forgiati nel
nucleo delle stelle miliardi di anni fa
allo stesso modo le foreste portano in
sé la traccia di eventi lontani nel
tempo e nello spazio
prendiamo gli anelli di accrescimento
annuali degli alberi negli anelli noi
possiamo leggere non solo l'età delle
piante ma anche la pioggia il caldo il
freddo del passato registrati
nell'ampiezza di ciascun anello così che
leggendo oggi questi diari naturali
siamo in grado di ricostruire il clima
di decennio centinaia di anni fa e
capire come stia cambiando
per esempio quasi tutti gli alberi della
terra si ricordano della più grande
eruzione vulcanica registrata in tempi
storici
quella del vulcano tambora in indonesia
in poco meno di un anno la cenere fece
il giro della terra si disperse in tutta
l'atmosfera causando una stagione così
fredda e umida che il 1816 venne
ricordato come l'anno senza estate
quell'anno gli alberi crebbero molto
meno e ancora oggi troviamo la traccia
di questa eruzione nell'anello di
accrescimento del 1816 improvvisamente
più stretto di tutti gli altri
molte altre cose accaddero in quell anno
senza estate gli eserciti di napoleone
si impantana rono nel terreno
inaspettatamente zuppo a waterloo nella
campagna svizzera un gruppo di amici
scrittori fu costretto a passare gran
parte dell'estate al chiuso
tra di loro una 19enne mary shelley
scrisse frankestein i tramonti nei cieli
del nord europa si colorano di rosso a
causa della cenere vulcanica che era
ancora dispersa nell'aria come vediamo
ancora oggi nel l'urlo di munch
ecco ogni volta che guarderete questo
quadro da oggi in poi potrete percepire
quanto siamo connessi a tutto quello che
avviene sul pianeta anche se non ce ne
accorgiamo pure le foreste oggi ci
legano alla terra e rendono possibile la
vita più di un miliardo di persone nel
mondo dipende dalle foreste per bere
acqua pulita
gli alberi inoltre trattengono il
terreno con le radici intercettano la
pioggia con le foglie la fanno
infiltrare lentamente nel suolo con il
loro humus diminuendo così la velocità
del deflusso e proteggendo chi abita a
valle da frane e alluvioni
il carbonio che gli alberi assorbono
grazie alla fotosintesi viene sottratto
all'atmosfera e questo ci aiuta nella
lotta ai cambiamenti climatici che senza
le foreste sarebbero del 30 per cento
più intensi l'assorbimento di carbonio
poi può essere prolungato
se facciamo rivivere gli alberi nel loro
legno le travi del tetto di alcune
malghe baite di montagna ci dimostrano
che il legno può trattenere carbonio al
suo interno per decine o centinaia di
anni e oggi l'edilizia in legno sta
vivendo una nuova primavera gli
architetti di tutto il mondo si sfidano
a costruire edifici in legno sempre più
alti di design grazie alle nuove
opportunità offerte dal mas timber
dall'islam
in fondo il legno che usiamo tutti i
giorni negli oggetti di casa nostra ci
connette a tutta la terra all'aria che è
servita per far crescere gli alberi
all'acqua e al suolo che li hanno
nutriti alle mani e la fantasia di chi
li sa lavorati per noi purtroppo in
italia quando usiamo legno ci
connettiamo invece spesso a ingiustizie
ambientali o sociali
nonostante le nostre foreste siano in
aumento quasi l'ottanta per cento del
legno che utilizziamo proviene
dall'estero e di questo un quinto da
foreste che sono tagliate in modo
illegale o insostenibile come negli
stati del sud america o dell'europa
dell'est
le foreste sono un ecosistema delicato
se non sono gestite nel modo corretto
rischiano di perdersi e con loro la
qualità della vita di chiederle foreste
dipende per acqua cibo lavoro una parte
dei migranti climatici che oggi sono
costretti a spostarsi in ampie parti del
mondo sono spinti a partire dalla
deforestazione e dagli effetti che la
deforestazione a sulla sicurezza
alimentare sull'accesso all'acqua e
sulla salute
esistono invece strategie per aumentare
l'uso del legno in modo sostenibile
dalle nostre foreste evitando gli
impatti a lunga distanza e garantendo al
tempo stesso la conservazione della loro
biodiversità e della funzione di
protezione del suolo per esempio si
tratta di scegliere le piante da
tagliare in modo da lasciare spazio e
luce alle nuove piantine che nel
frattempo si saranno sviluppate dai semi
e gli alberi intorno hanno disperso
nell'ambiente e che crescendo
garantiranno che la foresta nel suo
complesso
continua a prosperare scegliere quali
piante tagliare e quali lasciare quali
foreste possono darci legno in modo
sostenibile e quali invece è prioritario
gestire e conservare per la loro
diversità
è il compito della pianificazione
forestale
un compito che deve impostare oggi
quello che vogliamo che accada tra 50 o
100 anni perché la lentezza con cui
crescono le foreste ci obbliga a
connetterci con una percezione del tempo
radicalmente diversa dalla nostra
guardando al futuro poi non possiamo
dimenticare i cambiamenti climatici
oggi l'aumento di temperatura di siccità
causa ondate di mortalità nelle foreste
di tutto il mondo può propagare
facilitare la propagazione di incendi
molto vasti come abbiamo visto in italia
nell'estate del 2017 e causare la
drastica riduzione della superficie
occupata da alcune specie forestali come
già stiamo osservando nelle alpi
in più un atmosfera più energetica
significa una maggiore probabilità che
si verifichino alcuni eventi estremi
come gli schianti da vento che si sono
verificati in trentino in friuli in
veneto
un fenomeno che non ha precedenti
storici in italia
questi cambiamenti sono molto più veloci
della capacità delle piante di evolversi
e di adattarsi ma forse possiamo aiutare
gli alberi ad attraversarli ad esempio
facendoli crescere in modo che resistano
un po di più al vento o assicurandoci
che esista una giovane generazione di
piantine pronta a partire in caso di
catastrofe naturale
prendiamo per esempio un piccolo seme di
faggio il faggio è una specie un po
speciale
contrariamente la maggior parte delle
piante che si riproducono ogni anno come
ci aspetteremmo da un organismo che è
interessato a diffondersi a colonizzare
l'ambiente che lo circonda il faggio
invece funziona a intermittenza in
alcuni anni produce moltissimo seme in
altri poco o nessuno la cosa
straordinaria è che questa variabilità e
sincronizzata puntualmente tra albero e
albero tra foresta e foresta anche su
grandi distanze come tra le faggete
delle alpi e quelle della foresta nera
in germania con il nostro team di
ricerca abbiamo scoperto che questa
variabilità in realtà è causata da una
ben precisa sequenza climatica e
necessaria prima un'estate fresca e
umida per aumentare la disponibilità di
sostanze nutritive nel terreno e subito
dopo una calda e secca per spingere le
piante e le gemme a produrre fiori
anziché foglie e se le sostanze
nutritive si sono accumulate la
fioritura avrà in massa e con essa la
produzione di frutti e di semi questa
sequenza inoltre è legata ai cicli
dell'attività solare quando il sole è
più attivo il clima sulla terra è un po
più variabile discontinuo imprevedibile
e così è più probabile che si susseguano
stagioni molto diverse tra di loro come
nel caso di una fredda e umida e di una
calda e secca
subito dopo questo fenomeno ha
ripercussioni su tutti gli ecosistemi
anzitutto sul numero di germogli e di
piantine che possono rappresentare il
futuro della foresta soprattutto se
queste annate di iper produzione di seme
si verificano subito dopo un incendio
da qui la foresta quindi può riprendersi
molto più facilmente e poi a casa
creata con effetti sempre più ampi sul
numero dei mammiferi che si nutrono di
quei semi sui parassiti che trasportano
come le zecche per esempio o loro ospite
un po sgradevole
il batterio del morbo di lyme ancora
sulle concentrazioni dei pollini che
sono prodotti da quei fiori e che
possono causare un picco nelle allergie
ecco i cicli dei semi di faggio ci
raccontano le storie delle connessioni
che attraversano la natura dal seme al
sole fino ad arrivare a noi quasi a
rispecchiare lo stesso legame che
accomuna i nostri atomi con quello che
avviene nel nucleo delle stelle quando
muoveva i primi passi nelle alpi
piemontesi non avrei mai immaginato di
diventare uno scienziato a dir la verità
volevo fare il contadino come suggerisce
il significato originale del mio nome
giorgio ma guardavo l'ambiente che mi
circondava mi lasciavo meravigliare
dagli alberi dalle farfalle dai cieli
stellati e capivo che tutte le cose
erano in qualche modo collegate tra di
loro una rete di relazioni in cui mi
sentivo a casa
piccolo forse ma non insignificante
studiare
questa continua a raccontarmi le storie
delle relazioni che percorrono gli
ecosistemi anche a grandissima distanza
un fenomeno affascinante di cui posso
addirittura farmi canale raccontando a
voi oggi qui di alberi e di legno di
semi e di incendi e aprendo una
connessione attraverso cui ciascuno di
voi possa sentirsi parte integrante
dell'ecosistema riconoscendosi al tempo
stesso una sua causa e un suo effetto
che ce ne accorgiamo noi noi
apparteniamo a queste relazioni e gli
alberi e legno come grandi connettori
legano alla nostra vita a quella di
tante altre persone sulla terra vicine e
lontane che sono venute o che verranno
piccole ma non insignificanti tutt'uno
col pianeta reti di relazioni con altri
uomini
e questo è quello che per me significa
vivere grazie
[Applauso]